본인이 버리지 못하는 물건들이 좀 있으세요?
추억 물품들을 되게 많이 보관하고 있는 것 같아요.
전여친 사진 뭐 이런 거.
편지들.
전여친 사진은 없어요.
제가 재밌는 질문 하나 드릴까요?
꼭 하나씩 있는 물품이 있어요.
부피가 큰데 자주 사용하지 않는데 버릴 순 없다.
이야 이거 댓글 봅시다, 댓글.
똑같습니다.
남편이래, 남편.
남편이라고?
자 오늘은요 좀 특별한 방송.
아이엠 박스 남성훈 대표님 어서 오십시오.
아 예 안녕하십쇼.
아 예 근데 머리가 너무 천천히 해가지고.
그래서 저도 잘 안 써요.
좀 벗어, 벗어, 벗어.
저희가 이제 그랬잖아요.
사연을 이렇게 모아서 여러분들의 방을 한 번 좀 보고 싶다.
공간에 대한 이야기를 한 번 해보면 어쩔까?
20대 초반부터 40대까지 많은 분들이 보내주셨는데
딱 느낀 게 생각보다 더럽게 사신다.
아니 더럽다기보다는 현업이 좀 바쁘시다.
아 아니 뭐 다 욕해놓고서는 뒤에서 마무리, 이거 마무리 되나 이게?
아 죄송합니다.
정리에 대한 좀 꿀팁이 필요하다라는 생각이 좀 들었습니다.
저도 원룸 생활을 엄청 오래 했어요.
나도 새록새록 기억이 나더라고요.
아니 근데 대표님도 고향에서 올라오셨다고 들었거든요.
전라남도 순천이라고.
제가, 제가 순천박씨예요.
아 그래요?
이런, 이런 면이?
아니 역시 나랑 머리살도 비슷했어.
그쪽 지방이 원래 우리 이렇게 자르잖아요.
아 맞습니다, 예.
아 순천컷이라고 하는군요, 순천컷.
아 순천컷.
올라와가지고 노량진, 동촌동.
동촌동, 서울대구 그쪽에서 이제 오래 자취를 했죠.
아이엠박스 서비스는 어떻게 시작하게 된 거예요?
제가 원래 소프트웨어 개발하는 회사, 쇼핑몰 하는 회사를 운영을 했었는데
온라인 기반의 서비스는 투자를 못 받거나 또는 수익을 내기가 되게 힘들더라고요.
현금 흐름이 좋은 온라인하고 오프라인이 결합된 사업을 하자 하고
이렇게 인터넷에 검색을 했죠.
돈 되는 사업.
네이버에.
네, 유망한 사업만 이렇게 검색을 해봤죠.
아니 그러니까 사업을 이제 시작했는데 인터넷에서 검색을 해가지고 뭘, 뭘 할까?
첫 GPT한테 여쭤보는 거.
그치, 뭘 할까?
그러다가 정말 우연치 않게 셀프 스토리지라는 산업이 있는 거예요.
자세히 좀 찾아보니까 일본, 미국은 시장 엄청나게 큰데
어? 그런가 보다 하고 이제 잊고 지났습니다.
그리고 이제 며칠 있다가 보니까 저도 이제 지방에서 올라와가지고
제 짐을 그 친구 집에 맡겨놨거든요.
아, 짐을 친구한테?
어? 그럼 나같이 이렇게 짐을 맡겨야 되는 수요가 꽤 많이 있겠다 라고 생각해가지고
이 아이엠박스를 거의 한 11년 전에 시작하게 됐습니다.
아, 11년 전에.
그러면 나도 창업할까?
셀프 스토리지를 연간 계약을 하고 거기서 살아도 되나요?
네.
그럼 아이엠박스가 아니지. 아이엠 모텔.
아이엠 모텔.
그러신 분들도 있으십니까, 혹시?
근데 그러니까 저희가 정확하게는 모르겠는데
있긴 있을 것 같긴 해요.
아, 그래요? 있어요?
거기서 사는 건 아니고 와이프한테 쫓겨날 거라.
지금 고시원이랑 똑같은 구조잖아요.
그러니까요.
여기에 이제 사람이 사는 게 아니고 짐이 삽니다.
와, 근데 이렇게 깔끔하게 되어 있네요.
문밖에 없는데 라고 생각하실 수 있지만
여기에 좀 기술력이 많이 들어가 있어요.
아, 기술력이?
어떤 게 있어요?
그러니까 여기에 출입을 할 때 아무나 출입을 할 수가 없습니다.
결제를 하면 QR코드가 발급이 되고
그 QR코드를 찍고 들어가야 되고
보안이 되게 철저하다.
보안이 엄청 철저하고 온 습도가 자동으로 감지가 되고
또 하나 중요한 게 아파트 같은 경우는 지금 베란다가 없잖아요.
다 이렇게 확장을 하니까.
왼쪽 사진을 보시면 어떤 고객분께서
수납장을 자기가 가져와 가지고 짐을 이렇게 보관하고 계시는 겁니다.
만약에 이렇게 선반을 하게 된다고 하면 짐이 정말 엄청나게 들어갑니다.
근데 혹시 얼마 정도인가요?
가장 많이 사용하는 사이즈가 가로 1m, 세로 1m
높이가 대략 2.4m 정도 되는데
2.4m?
저희가 지역마다 지금 좀 차이가 있어요.
약간 경기도 외곽에 있는 데는 되게 저렴하게 5, 6만 원짜리도 있고
서울 쪽은 메인 거리 조금 비싼 한 10만 원 이상 되는 데도 있고
수요와 공급에 따라서 좀 차이가 있는
아마 이 공간을 가족들한테 들키면 안 돼서 보관하시는 분들 꽤 있을 거예요.
골프나 피규어 막 이런 거
피규어, 낚시, 낚시 장비 이런 거 아마 와이프 몰래 창고에다가
박 팀장님은 맡기게 된다면 뭘 맡기고 싶어요?
싶으신지
저요? 저는 그런 거 없습니다.
여기선 말 못 하죠.
아니 이미 이용하고 계시는 거 아니에요?
있으신 거 아니에요?
난 없어. 난 깨끗해.
이용하고 계실 수 있을 것 같습니다.
이제 시청자 참여 콘텐츠가 또 있잖아요.
이름이 되게 익숙하구나.
익숙하다. 익숙해.
저는 한 회사의 대표입니다.
직원 중 한 명이 대표는 모자를 써야 한다면서
어디서 이상한 모자를 하나씩씩 하더니 그 모자 제가 또 쓰고 있습니다.
이게 저희 지금 회사입니다.
이 테이블이요. 슈카월드 하시는
슈카 님 이렇게 나오는 거 알고 있어요.
지금
몰라요.
몰래 찍었습니다.
제가 봤을 때는 얘를 위쪽으로 옮겨야 돼요. 위쪽
물론 뭐 팔이 좀 안 닿을 수 있겠지만
이거라도 좀 쳐내야 돼요.
그럼 니냉님만 꺼내실 수 있는 거 아니에요?
280cm
2m 정도 되시는 분들을 이제 우리는 직원 채용해야겠죠.
슈카친구들 PD, 지PD입니다.
보시다시피 복층 원룸이고
고민과 비용이 들었던 걸 기억하는데 처음에 엄청난 고민을 했대요.
그리고 이분이 영화즈를 모으는 덕후입니다.
이게 복층에 위에서 올라가서 찍은 거거든요.
자기 거실을 이 벽에다가 포스터들을 이렇게
본인의 취향으로 꾸미는 거죠. 이 공간에
빔이에요, 빔.
그리고 여기 혼자 앉을 수 있는 쇼파
편집도 하고 음악도 듣고 이 작은 공간 안에서
이런 사람들이 있으면 아임박스 사업이 망합니다.
그렇죠. 너무 정리를 잘하잖아요.
대표님이나 박 팀장님은
이렇게 본인만의 공간이 있다 하면 어떻게 꾸미실 것 같아요?
저는 개인적으로 식물을 좀 좋아해가지고
행운을 가져다주는 식물이 좀 많이 있어가지고
생기신 거는 세일러분인 것 같아요.
헬스장 관장같이 생겼다고 생각해요.
그다음에 제가 짱구를 좀 좋아해가지고
거실에는 짱구 피규어가 좀 많습니다.
팀장님은 혹시 뭐 어떻게 꾸미고 싶으신 게 있으세요?
술병으로 다 도배를 하고 싶어요.
막 이렇게 막 이거보다도 이런 술도 한번 맛보고 싶고
맛있는 술?
이런 맥주도 한번 맛보고 싶고 이런 거는 있거든요.
물론 등짝 스매싱 막혀있잖아요.
근데 그거를 아임박스에서 혹시
아, 내가 지금 실수한 것 같아.
지금 해놓으신 거 아닙니까?
자, 사연자입니다.
빠동님.
어쩔 수 없이 광파오븐이랑 밥솥 때문에 문에 들어와서 거실로 가려면
통곡의 벽이 하나가 생기게 되네요.
식탁을 줄이고 광파오븐 수납장 옮기는 게 맞을지
이 통곡의 벽.
자, 어떻게 배치해야 되느냐?
이건 숙헌 냄새 난다.
남자들은요.
쌀.
어, 쌀.
그렇지.
쌀은 식탁 위에 있어야 돼.
이봐, 이봐.
내가 얘기했잖아.
이거 절대 빼서 냉장고에 넣지 않습니다.
그리고 이 세탁소에 있는 그 비닐.
그대로 놔둔 거야.
원래 이게 우리 남자들의 특이야.
그냥 그대로 놔두는 거야.
제가 볼 때는 이 친구는 아임박스에 필요 없어요.
짐이 너무 없는데요.
짐이 없잖아.
없잖아.
이것만 빼서 이 안에다가 넣을 수 있을 것 같고.
남는 공간에 다른 사람의 짐을 보관해주고.
아, 그래야.
이야, 천재야.
천재야.
자, 넘어갈까요?
선우입니다.
미니멀 라이프를 등진 맥시멈 라이프를 사러 온 아내 집이다.
우리 아내가 물건을 버리지 못한대요.
이야, 버리기가 못 버릴 것 같아요.
의미가 있겠네요.
돌, 이거 봐.
돌을 폐처럼 키우는 거 아십니까?
아, 예. 그렇습니다.
물도 주고.
밥도 줘요?
밥도 주고.
응.
본인이 버리지 못하는 물건들이 좀 있어요.
저는 예전에 사용했던 추억 물품들을
좀 되게 많이 보관하고 있는 것 같아요.
전 여친 사진, 뭐 이런 거.
편지들.
전 여친 사진은 없어요.
제가 이제 사이클을 탔었는데
제가 오피스텔에 살았거든요.
사이클은 생각보다 되게 애매해요.
부피가 좀 커, 생각보다.
맞아, 맞아, 맞아.
사이클 하시면 다 밖에 빼서 따로 보관하시잖아요, 그렇죠?
저희가 엄복동의 나라라서
고가의 자전거 놔두면 다 훔쳐가잖아요.
맞아요.
근데 이제 자전거를 정말 자주 타면
일주일에 한 번 정도.
두 번 탔는데
이게 잘 안 타다 보니까
버리기에는 애매하고
가끔은 찾게 되는 그런 물품들을
되게 창고에 많이 보관해놨습니다.
아직 결혼 안 하셨어요, 근데?
아, 예. 아직 안 했습니다.
아직 안 하셨어요?
보자, 걔다.
자, 지금 지점이 220개가 넘어가고 있습니다.
아, 저희가 살짝 나이트 삐끼처럼 지금
혼자 하셨어요, 사실.
막 손잡고 어디 막 데려가서
나한테 이제 한 20만 원씩.
아유, 고생했어.
자, 안녕하세요. 머니코믹스 애청자입니다.
초등학교 1학년 아들방을
부끄러움을 무릅쓰고 올립니다라고 해서
야, 이거 뭐냐?
걸렸다, 낚시야.
자, 우리 레이더에 걸렸습니다.
실제로 저희 신도시 쪽에
신혼부부분들이 많이 살잖아요.
실제로 이런 분들이 짐을 진짜 많이 맡깁니다.
예전에는 뭐 유모차라든가 사용하지 않는 걸
다 베란다에 막 이렇게 밀어넣는데
맞아, 맞아.
지금 이제 베란다가 없잖아요.
그래서 요즘 신축 아파트들은
그 세대창고를 주긴 하는데
짐을 맡기기 좀 애매하거든요.
제가 사는 아파트도 세대창고가 있긴 한데
거기 써 있어요, 짐 맡기지 말라고.
네? 세대창고인데요?
왜요?
민감한 거 맡기지 말라고.
거기가 또 다 철조망으로 돼 있는데
그냥 안이 다 보입니다.
제가 재밌는 질문을 하나 드릴까요?
꼭 하나씩 있는 물품이 있어요.
아, 궁금하다.
부피가 큰데 자주 사용하지 않는데
버릴 수는 없다.
이야, 자, 이거 댓글 봅시다, 댓글.
똑같습니다.
남편이래, 남편.
자주 사용하지 않는데 부피는 커.
꼭 하나씩 있는.
캐리어.
여행 캐리어.
아, 맞아.
캐리어가 은근히 너무 짜증나요.
캐리어는
부피가 크고
캐리어는 큰데 버릴 수는 없고
자주 사용하지 않는
딱 이런 거를 이제 창고에 넣어 놓는.
그럼 남편도 보관할 수 있고
캐리어도 보관할 수 있고.
마지막 거지왕.
6평 다가구 집에서 전세 왔다.
사회 초년생인데
지금 내가 좋은 집에 안 살고
6평짜리 집에 살면서
CD를 모아야 될지
넓은 집으로 갈지
그게 고민이시라고 말씀하시는 거거든요.
제가 이분한테는 정말 좋은 솔루션을 줄 수 있을 것 같아요.
CD를 모으는 게 중요할 것 같은데
더 넓은 데로 이사 가게 되면
주거비가 되게 많이 드니까
이 물품들은
아임박스 같은 데 맡기는 게 좋을 것 같은데
가격이 너무 부담된다고 하면
쉐어 기능도 있어요.
친구랑 같이 쓸 수 있어요, 친구랑.
그렇게 하면 짐을 맡기고
조금 더 공간을 넓혀서
CD를 더 모으면서 이렇게
왜냐면 지금 저도 많이 느끼는 게
요즘 되게 안타까운 것 중에 하나가
주거비가 지금 너무 올라가고 있어가지고
맞아 맞아 너무 비싸요.
지금 서울 같은 경우는
거의 전체 소득의 30-40%가
주거비로 나간다고 하더라고요.
제가 작은 방에 있다가
저도 이제 CD를 딱 모았지
그걸로 이제 단타를 쳐요.
그래서 이제 다 잃어.
그래서 고시원으로
그러다가 이제
제 와이프가 저를 구제해 줬습니다.
비교적 최근까지 그러셨던 거예요?
말이 그렇다는 얘기지.
그걸 뭐 일일이 내가 뭐
CD가 생기면 혼자 있는 남자는
뭔가 뭘 해야 됐다라고 생각이 들고
이걸로 뻥튀기 시켜야 된다라는
이 강박관념이 있어가지고
곱하기 2, 3을 뭐 보게 되고
아 저거 오늘 사업가 가겠는데?
이러면 이제 거기서 단타 치고
그리고 제 경험에서 봤을 때
저도 이제 이사를 되게 자주 다녔거든요.
근데 이사를 자주 다니다 보면
조금 조금
계속 무리를 하게 되는 것 같아요.
제가 생각했을 때는
이 주거비라는 게 사실
너무 나가는 비용이 많으니까
좋은 데 살고 싶은 거는
모든 사람들의 어떤 꿈이지만
주거비를 아껴가지고
그 돈으로 투자를 한다든가
다른 걸 해서
더 많은 돈을 모으게 되면
그 다음에 더 좋은 데로 가는 게 맞으니까
주거비를 최대한 아낄 수 있는 방안이 뭘까?
여기를 좀 고민하는 게
좀 중요하지 않을까 생각합니다.
우리 또 아임 박스 저희 대표님 나오셨는데
지금까지 우리가 사연회를 통해가지고
뭐 여러 가지 이야기를 했지만
결국에는 이게 도대체 어떻게 지금 사업적으로 좀 되고 있는가
그 부분 좀 부탁드리겠습니다.
아마 모든 분들이 되게 생소할 거예요.
이 산업 자체가 세계적으로는 엄청나게 큰 비즈니스다.
미국은 땅이 넓은데 왜 이렇게 많이 사용하지?
라고 생각할 수 있을 것 같아요.
자기가 살고 있는 집에 한 평의 임대료보다
창고 한 평의 임대료가 훨씬 저렴하기 때문에
집에 놔두기 애매한 걸 전부 다 창고에 맡기는 상황입니다.
한국도 근데 지금 임대료가 엄청나게 많이 올라가고 있잖아요.
궁금한 게요?
네.
아임 박스는 다른 경쟁사랑 비교했을 때
뭔가 차별점이 각 경쟁사마다 있습니까 이게?
저희는 셀프 스토리지를 부동산업으로 접근을 했어요.
이 사업을 플랫폼 사업을 볼 거냐
부동산 사업을 볼 거냐 약간 관점이 차이인데
저희 구성원 대부분이 부동산 전문가들로 구성이 돼 있어서
입지라든가 상권이라든가 수익률이라든가
이런 거 철저하게 분석을 많이 해서 지점을 오픈하고 있고
더 잘 될 수 있도록
제가 최근에 글로벌 대도시를 좀 많이 다니면서
부동산 업무를 좀 많이 했어요.
제 그냥 정말 지극히 개인적인 생각을
주거용 부동산 특히 아파트 같은 경우는
제가 생각했을 때 가격이 그렇게 많이 오르지 않을 것 같아요.
앞으로.
앞으로?
지금 이 비싼 아파트를 살 수요가 많이 없습니다.
그러다 보면 지금 우리나라도 특히 서울 수도권도
다른 글로벌 대도시와 비슷하게 할 것 같은데
그럼 어떻게 될 거냐
메인 요지 강남이나 특정 구간은 우상향할 가능성이 크지만
그 외 지역은 자산 가격 특히 아파트 같은 경우가
자산 가격이 오르지 않거나 살짝 전반적으로 내려가되
그 대신 월세화가 많이 진행이 돼서
주거비는 올라갈 것 같아요.
그러니까 뉴욕이 집값이 엄청 비쌀 거라고 생각하잖아요.
근데 전체적으로 보면 뉴욕이랑 서울 집값이 약간 비슷합니다.
그러니까 엄청 비싼 거 제외하고
근데 뉴욕 같은 경우는 쉽게 집을 살 수가 없어요.
쉽게 얘기하면 약간 투자재가 아니고
정말 가서 살 사람만 살 수 있는 구조예요.
보유세 같은 것도 되게 높고 세금도 많이 내야 돼가지고
한국 같이 내가 안 사는데 그냥 전세 껴서 투자를 해야 된다
이런 관점으로 접근할 수 없는 거고
그러니까 셀프 스토리지라는 업이 되게 재밌는 게
거의 유일하게 상업용 부동산과 주거용 부동산이
엄청나게 밀접하게 연관이 되어 있는 업이에요.
주거용 부동산이 가격이 오르면 셀프 스토리지 수요가 엄청나게 늘고
이 상업용 부동산이 오히려 가격이 늘면
셀프 스토리지 오히려 안 좋아집니다.
수익성이 떨어지기 때문에
그러다 보니까 지금 큰 대도시 같은 데는
이 셀프 스토리지가 상업용 부동산의 엄청나게 큰 메인 섹터인데
한국은 아직 시작하는 단계여가지고
사람들이 인식이 조금 많이 없지
앞으로 이런 추세면 엄청나게 빠르게 성장할 거라고 확신을 하고 있습니다.
예전에 되게 가슴이 아팠던 게 뭐냐면
제가 아까 말씀드린 거 같이 픽업을 한다고 했잖아요.
꽤 전에 저도 차를 타고 가서
느낀 게 뭐냐면
특히 1인 가구 위주로 해서
주거 환경이 열악한 사람이 진짜 너무 많은 거예요.
그걸 보면 되게 안타까웠거든요.
그래서 최대한 저렴하게 서비스를 제공하자 노력 많이 하고 있고
너무 가격이 비싸다고 생각하면
쉐어 서비스 같은 걸 이용해가지고
정말 쾌적하게 안전하게 보관할 수 있으니까
저렴하게 이용할 수 있는 방법은
신규 오픈한 지점은 할인을 많이 합니다.
투자자 관점으로 한번 말씀드리자면
지금 이게 상업용 부동산의 임대료 추이거든요.
2층부터 임대료가 확 내려갑니다.
경기도권을 보면 1층 평균 임대료는
1층 평균 임대료는
8만 원, 9만 원 조금 안 합니다.
셀프 스토리를 정말 추천드리는 이유가
수익률이 엄청 실제 높아요.
투자자 입장에서?
투자자 입장에서.
이 머니코믹스 채널에
투자에 관심 있는 분들이 정말 많잖아요.
셀프 스토리를 엄청 홍보하기보다는
이 업을 알면 장기적으로 도움이 많이 될 거예요.
왜냐하면 지금 많이 나오는 말이
3점 벌어서 강남 집 산다.
주거용 부동산이 막히니까
상업용 부동산으로 투자한다.
이런 말이 많은데
이 셀프 스토리를 하나의 보관 창고?
이렇게 접근하기보다는
상업용 부동산에서 입지도 안 좋고
수익이 나기 힘든 곳에
마지막으로 수익화를 할 수 있는 대안이
있구나라는 걸 아시면
아마 어떤 투자할 때 도움이 많이 되실 거예요.
그렇지.
근데 그 처음에
나 이제 사업해야지.
나 뭐 할까?
그때 뭐라고 치셨어요?
할 만한 사업을.
할 만한 사업.
내가 다 쳤는데 그걸 안 쳤네.
유망한 사업.
사업을 하면서요.
이게 2023년이라고 했잖아요.
팀장님 요즘 사업에 되게 관심이 많아요.
잠깐만.
직관님 안에 계신데 지금.
잘 썼다고.
잘 썼다고 얘기해주세요.
갑자기 오시는 거 아니에요?
아니요.
다른 사람.